Uh, we are considering this a hate crime
until it's not. Here's what we know
so far.
At about 11:43,
we received a call of an active shooter
at the Islamic Center.
Make dua for my swift recovery so that I
can get back to work during doing what I
love, protecting the Islamic Center of
San Diego.
What is success? To many people, success
is financial stability, good reputation,
beauty, etc. As for me, wallahi thumma
wallahi, it is
everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's what
Allah says,
hatta zurtum al-maqabir. You are busy
with the worldly affairs until you visit
the graves. Brothers and sisters, Masjid
Norway, the one that we built, is
looking to another masjid around the
area of Norway subhanallah where there's
so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masjid is only
$500,000 and any donation that you give
will go towards your akhirah because
when you enter that grave, nobody's
going to remember you except Allah
subhanallah wa ta'ala. So, make it
count, brothers and sisters, and donate
towards this masjid inshallah. A new
project that's only $500,000 and believe
me, if every single one of us give £1,
£10, £100, £1,000, that's going to be
something you will never regret on yawm
al-qiyamah and everything that you lose
is going to perish and go, but your
deeds on yawm al-qiyamah are not. Donate
to the link inshallah. Let's get to the
video. As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi
wa barakatuh, brothers and sisters and
dear friends. There has been a shooting
in San Diego where Sheikh Uthman Farooq
resides, lives, and does his dawah.
Uh, subhanallah,
Islamophobia,
um, people who are indoctrinated, uh, a
couple of days ago there was a march of
the far right to a scum individual who's
a Zionist Jew who was being quoted by
Epstein a cheap at any price a dirt bag
who's a cog head who was telling his
followers that the British people should
get ready befit the men for a fight.
Yes, God knows if these words were
inspired by these far rights who are
watching them in in in America.
Um three men have been killed in
San Diego. Two have been found dead in
the car. We don't know if these are the
individuals who actually
committed suicide by killing themself.
As far as I know and we don't know who
was involved in this
but it seems like it's a far rightest
and Islamophobic attack.
Um so the BBC can see here but before
that this is somebody that Farrokh knew
and himself was stabbed as we you know a
couple of years ago
doing amazing work exposing these
scumbags. So
and himself was stabbed. So if you can
read it as you can see on the screen
three men killed in San Diego
mosque shooting and two teen suspects
found dead in a car nearby says police.
Uh as you can see we'll just watch this
video.
We have our two suspects that are
deceased.
Uh we have three victims at the Islamic
Center.
All three are adults.
Uh for a total of five people that are
deceased
uh related to this incident. Cause of
the Islamic Center location
uh we are considering this a hate crime
until it's not. Here's what we know
so far.
At about 11:43
we received a call of an active shooter
at the Islamic Center.
Within four minutes
officers arrived arrived on scene and
observed immediately three deceased
what appeared to be deceased victims out
in front.
They immediately began to deploy
with an active shooter response
into the mosque
and adjacent school.
Moments later at the 3800 block of
Hatton,
officers were called to that location
where they found a vehicle in the middle
of the street
with who we believe to be the shooters
in this incident, both deceased.
This is every community's worst
nightmare.
We have three confirmed
adults
that are deceased
at the Islamic Center.
Both suspects in this case are deceased.
All of the kids
are safe.
Hate has no place in the city of San
Diego, and when it happens and crime of
any nature occurs, we will hold you
accountable. I want to assure
our Muslim community that we will do
everything it takes to make sure that
you can feel safe in this city. Uh and
no resource will be spared in making
sure that our religious institutions and
and locations are protected in this
sensitive time.
Subhanallah. And what gets more
beautiful? I mean, it's sad and tragic,
but if you just knew what he posted,
brother Amin, who passed away.
If you knew the words he said, wallahi,
wallahi, it is a good ending.
I'm going to show you guys. Wallahi,
you're going to be shocked. Before that,
I just want to read what's happened.
Police say two suspects
uh are dead and the and third has been
neutralized after shooting at a San
Diego mosque.
Um three men were killed at the Islamic
Center of San Diego, including a
security guard, police say. Um the
bodies of two teenage suspects were
found in a vehicle nearby.
So, they took their own life.
Yes, okay. The FBI says that the
incident is currently being treated
treated as a hate crime. Islamic Center
in the
uh Clairemont [clears throat] area of
the city in the is the largest mosque in
San Die- San Diego. So, we me and
Muhammad Hijab went to his debate to
California and then we headed off to Los
Angeles. I don't know if we stopped at
San Diego, but this is
so tragic. Any life being taken by
anybody, subhanallah. Be it they are
Jew, Christian, Zionist for that matter.
Okay? A A A family innocent family
member, if if they are whoever they are.
Do you get what I'm trying to say? Cuz
they know how to teach us. Yes? Innocent
Zionist, yes? I'm not talking about this
idea of soldiers, these dirtbags. May
Allah subhana wa ta'ala destroy them.
Yes? I'm talking about these Zionist
individual brainwashing family members,
etc. You know, applauding what's going
on in Gaza. Even them, we wouldn't want
them to be
same thing happen to them that they want
to cause this to happen, subhanallah.
So, you can see here, brothers and
sisters, that this is what's happened on
the ground. The news is kind of covering
it. It's not a national national media
news. You don't see it everywhere
because it's Muslims. It's Muslims and
they don't really care about it.
Subhanallah in a nutshell. So, going to
this This is where it gets really
powerful, subhanallah, brothers and
sisters. Yeah. Bro- Look at brother
Amin's post. He was at Umrah. If you
look closely, yes? Okay, he was at Umrah
with Sheikh Uthman Farooq. If I'm not
mistaken, this is the brother, brother
Amin, if I'm not mistaken
from the pictures that I saw. That I
think this is him. Subhanallah. And as
you can see, Sheikh Uthman Farooq is
there amongst the brothers. Yes? May
Allah subhana wa ta'ala grant him the
highest ranks of Jannah. Now, look at
this, guys. This is where it gets Subha-
Actually,
this could bring bring you to tears.
Subhanallah, brothers and sisters. Look
at this. Look at his post
on Facebook.
They say this was when?
May the 5th.
"What is success? To many people,
success is financial stability, good
reputation, beauty, etc. As for me,
wallahi thumma wallahi, it is returning
back to Allah, our creator, with the
same pure soul he loaned me at birth."
Subhanallah. And there's an ayah in the
Quran about this.
Having the malaika of Allah Ta'ala
saying, "Don't fear and don't grieve,
but receive the glad tidings of Jannah
which you were promised by the most
forgiving, most merciful." May Allah
Ta'ala grant us husnul khatima, amen. A
good ending.
If his dua didn't get answered,
Subhanallah.
And this is when he had some kind of
injury and he was saying, "Make dua for
my swift recovery so that I can get back
to work during
doing what I love, protecting the
Islamic Center of San Diego."
I'm getting goosebumps.
I'm getting goosebumps. Subhanallah.
Subhanallah.
Look at the beautiful ending. "Don't
feel sorry for him, feel sorry for
yourself." And this goes to me.
Wallahi, go to the Quran now.
Look what Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala says.
As whoever kills a believer
intentionally, his recompense is in hell
where he will abide eternally, abadan.
And Allah will Allah will have wrath
upon him and curse him and will prepare
for him a great punishment. May Allah
destroy those people who've done this.
And you know what Allah says in the
Quran? Look at this. Look at this dua
that he made.
Assuring those who follow divine
guidance, believe in God and do
righteous deed that they will not
experience fear or grieve. Yeah, grieve,
yeah. Surah Baqarah. The foundational
promise given to humanity when Adam and
Eve went to Earth, whoever follows my
guidance, they will know have no fear.
Nor will they grieve. Surah Baqarah.
Um applies to believers, Jews,
Christians, and Sabians, yes? The
those of that their times, finally, yes?
Whoever believes in Allah in the last
day and does good deeds, they shall have
reward, nor shall they grieve. In Surah
Yunus, and a reassurance for the close
friends of Allah, awliya. Verily, no
fear shall be upon the friends of Allah,
nor shall they grieve. May Allah Subhana
Wa Ta'ala make us uh the friends friend
of Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala. Surah A'raf,
for those who who faith in Allah and
remain steadfast, they will know have no
fear concerning them till that day. Not
only that, subhanallah, this verse here,
Allah subhana wa ta'ala says, Allah
makes the believers steadfast with firm
in this world world
and in the hereafter. Allah leaves the
wrongdoers astray for Allah subhana wa
ta'ala does what he wills.
Allah is giving you a promise. If you
live by la ilaha illallah,
YOU WILL DIE BY LA ilaha illallah
if you live by it.
If you make it your own,
not the money,
not the this, not the looks, not the
cars, not the bags, not the luxury, not
the holidays, not this that ALL THESE
DUMB THINGS THAT we'll put our attention
to and sleepless nights worrying about
this and I have to drive that and do
that. The biggest enslavement brother
Amin showed us
that he put his life on the line and not
only that, we have heard from private
messages that we know
that he is the one who saved hundreds of
children's lives because he was the
guard and he gave the code that there's
an active shooter, lock the doors.
And he reminds me
the ayah in the Quran that was given to
send the Bani Isra'il
and whoever saves one soul is as if he
saved the whole of humanity. Not only
did he want to go to Jannah, HE GOT IT.
NOT ONLY was he firm in la ilaha
illallah, he died on la ilaha illallah.
And may Allah grant him the highest
ranks of Jannah.
And Allah will make his word firm.
Yes.
And he saved the souls of hundreds of
children and told them, "Lock the
doors." The shooters couldn't get in.
He died for the believers.
He lived by Allah,
proclaimed Allah on his tongue, died for
the believers,
protected those children. This man is a
man
that should be looked up to. This is a
man that should be the role model
in our times.
Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam, of
look at that.
It really amazes me.
Amazes me.
And death will come to us at any time.
Death will come to us at any time.
And those who fear will let me tell you
something, don't fear.
If you
and there's a Hadith of the Prophet,
those who fear Allah in this dunya will
not fear Allah in the afterlife.
And those who do not fear Allah in this
dunya will fear Allah in the afterlife.
That's why Allah says in the name of
Allah the most gracious in the name of
Allah the most gracious. With hardship
comes ease. If you go through the
hardship of this life, you will have
ease in the afterlife. If you try to
enjoy the ease and do whatever you want,
you're going to have hardship because
with hardship comes ease. The opposite
is true, with ease comes hardship. You
do ease now, you'll pay for the
suffering at the end.
And believe me, I swear to Allah
Allah gives you the promise of making
you firm. Your Your word firm.
Meaning, in that grave when you are
asked that question, don't think it's
something you're going to memorize. It
is the heart. Allah will make you firm.
You're not going to be scared. Don't
think that grave you're going to be
scared. You're going to be firm.
When the angels ask you, "Who is your
Lord?" Allah.
Firm.
Who was the prophet that was sent to
you?
Muhammad, peace be upon him.
What is your religion? Religion?
Islam.
Brothers and sisters, I swear to Allah,
prioritize your afterlife.
Do not lose the afterlife for the dunya
for you will not get the dunya and the
afterlife. And anyone that sacrifices
dunya for the afterlife, Allah will give
him the dunya and the afterlife.
May Allah grant our brother Amin the
highest ranks of Jannah. What an
honorable man. What an honorable man.
A soldier who stood up for his
community, people, and for anyone.
And his beautiful post of wanting
nothing but returning back to Allah
with the pure heart.
Well, he said, "Remind me of this
verse."
In the Quran, Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
says, as Prophet Ibrahim prayed, "And do
not disgrace me on the day they are all
resurrected, the day when they will not
be of benefit to anyone, whether wealth
or children,
but only those who come with to Allah
with the sound heart."
Qalb-e-Saleem.
And he made dua for that.
May Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala give him the
highest ranks of Jannah.
>> [sighs]
>> Brothers and sisters,
may Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala protect the
Muslimin around the world.
Forgive us our shortcomings and give us
a good ending.
Brothers and sisters, this life is going
to end.
Allah will ask us, "How long did you
live on Earth?" You will say, "A day or
a portion of a day."
Let it count. Invest where it matters.
In your akhirah, your children, sadaqah
jariyah.
May Allah bless and preserve you guys,
brothers and sisters.
There is, as you know, brothers and
sisters, Subhanallah, we are
trying to build a masjid in Norway.
Please, when you're donating, remember
the Muslims that are dead or alive, and
brother Amin, and do sadaqah jariyah on
his behalf as as well.
Till next time, Assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.